Salut internet, cette semaine j'ai décidé de vous parler d'un casse tête parce que cet été j'en fais pas mal.
Sûrement le plus beau casse tête que j'ai vu en terme de réalisation, c'est le cadenas 64.
Alors c'est l'un des plus durs aussi.
Mais il est juste très très joli, fabriqué en Allemagne avec du bois précieux, je vous raconterai tout ça dans la vidéo,
parce que le temps que je cherche, je pense qu'on aura bien bien le temps de parler.
N'hésitez pas aussi à me suivre sur mon instagram je vais faire des gros plans et des ralentis de tous les détails de ce casse-tête
là, comme ça si vous voulez en voir plus vous allez sur mon IGTV, je fais des petites vidéos en plus en ce moment.
Voilà ça fait plaisir. Viens, viens sur mon insta et tu verras des vidéos que tu ne vois pas ailleurs !
Bon le principe il est très clair, il va falloir l'ouvrir, je sais pas encore s'il y a un principe de
combinaisons ou pas, on va voir ça tout ça ensemble.
Et tant que j'y suis aussi à ce moment là je vous rappelle que le spectacle
Singularité, mon troisième spectacle, est à l'Olympia le 22 septembre,
que la salle est presque pleine, on est à plus de 80 % de remplissage donc si vous voulez venir,
je pense que même si on est l'été, il est temps de penser à venir en fait dans ces cas là.
Voici le cadenas
64. Comme je vous disais tout à l'heure, je pense que c'est l'un des plus beaux cadenas que j'ai jamais vu en terme de finition
en termes de travail, de finesse, c'est fait en bois de padouk, en padouk. Je ne sais pas ce qu'est le bois de padouk
vous savez vous me dites ce qu'est le bois de padouk dans les commentaires, et en érable, et ça a été fait par deux co auteurs en
Allemagne. Bon après c'est du travail artisanal comme d'hab. Qu'est ce que je peux vous dire ? Je peux vous dire
que c'est magnifique déjà, je vous le fais bien voir.
L'objectif il est très clair, c'est qu'il faut ouvrir le cadenas, il faut le libérer comme ça.
Et il y a une dernière indication qui était mis dans la notice
qui est que ça utilise un système à l'intérieur mécanique de résolution de cadenas qui n'a jamais été fait à ce jour. Donc dans un
premier temps comme d'hab,
exploration je vais chercher ce qui bouge.
Je pense pas qu'il y ai de système d'aimants autre chose comme ça,
ou peut-être que je me trompe et je le saurai plus tard, c'est même possible.
Ça, c'est complètement lâche ça sert à rien, ça tourne dans le vide.
Ici on a le cadran qui tourne donc de zéro où il y a une vraie butée,
et dans le sens inverse des aiguilles d'une montre jusqu'à 42 environ. Derrière on a
des trucs avec les vis ça je pense que c'est clairement pour la décoration. Ca serait tellement drôle que en forçant juste un petit peu ça fasse SCHBLAM !
Bon ben voilà c'est ouvert. Là on a une gravure :
numéro 00 64 point 0 0
Alors je pense pas que ce soit un numéro de série ou alors c'est un pur hasard parce qu'il s'appelle le cadenas 64.
J'espère qu'il n'y a pas
64 étapes non plus !
C'est peut-être la première fois que je fais un cadenas ou du moins un casse tête que j'arrive pas à résoudre dans la vidéo
parce que là on est sur une difficulté extrême hein sur celui-là. Il y a marqué security corp,
il y a deux points noirs de chaque côté mais ça c'est de la pyrogravure et
1871 qui peut être un indice aussi d'ailleurs.
Il faudrait voir si je peux faire 1 8 7 1. Bon si c'est ça la difficulté extrême
laisse tomber
Dans un premier temps comme d'habitude avec les casse-tête on va faire la phase d'exploration du casse-tête, voir ce qui est possible
de faire ou pas.
Donc ça on a vu que ça tournait.
Ca, ça tournait pour rien. Ca, bah forcément que c'était vérouillé et que c'est lié à ça parce que quand j'en bouge un
l'autre, il bouge. On voit clairement que ça et ça c'est lié.
Et puis le dos, ma foi, on oublie pour le moment. Là je vais faire un petit peu comme dans les films américains
Je vais me transformer en espion ou en voleur. C'est-à-dire que je ne vais pas faire de bruit
et je vais tourner lentement le cadenas pour voir si j'entends quelque chose. Vous savez j'avais déjà fait une vidéo sur le lock picking, c'est
l'ouverture de serrure en français et on va chercher des goupilles une par une en faisant une action mécanique forcée pour essayer d'entendre
ce qui se passe ou de voir ce qui se passe. C'est à peu près le
même concept que je vais, que je veux reproduire là. On verra si ça sert.
Et j'suis au 42. Donc là c'est assez incroyable entre le 0 et le 42 quand j'ai tourné, à aucun moment j'ai entendu
ou senti quelque chose.
Donc je garde mon principe de c'est peut-être comme une serrure
en lock picking, donc je vais, je vais faire une action mécanique, je vais je pense tirer, essayer de le tirer
et voir si à un moment donné il y a des crans qui se libèrent.
Parce que je me dis c'est peut-être comme dans les films, droite gauche droite droite gauche, alors voilà.
En fait j'aurais vraiment été tenté de tester le 1871 mais j'ai pas accès au 1 ni au 8 ni au 7
puisque c'est entre 0 et 42.
C'est reparti !
Donc là à 5 déjà j'ai réussi à lever un peu plus.
A 6 par contre ça le ramène. On le voit là ça redescend un petit peu.
Là j'arrive pas aller plus loin que 47.
Ah oui et plus je le ramène, plus je me fais coincer le doigt et plus il re-rentre.
Alors, après de longues, beaucoup trop longues minutes, état des lieux. Premier état des lieux quand je fais ça,
j'entends un truc dedans.
Comme une bille ou quelque chose, mais ça roule vraiment en fait entre mes doigts.
Vous entendez ?
Bienvenue dans cette vidéo d'ASMR. Le deuxième truc c'est que je
pense être dans le vrai avec le système gauche droite gauche droite, je pense pas qu'ils aient fait autre chose avec ça. Le vrai problème
c'est en termes d'indices, on n'a pas grand chose sur les chiffres possibles. Je pense qu'il y a un indice quelque part et les deux choses
que j'ai c'est 1871 ici et
0  64 point 0 0,
donc numéro 0 64 point
0 0 derrière. Le 1, le 8, le 7 et le 1 de toute manière, j'y ai pas accès pour le moment, je suis bloqué entre 0
et 42. Ah bah si, j'ai le 7 et le 8, bon
j'ai pas le 1. Mais moi quand je tourne ça, je ne sens pas d'entraîner quelque chose c'est comme si c'était tout libre, tout vide.
Du coup, je reviens sur mon idée de serrures je pense pas que ce soit cranté
je sais pas trop en fait ce que ça entraîne à l'intérieur dans la matrice. Quelle pilule choisis-tu Neo ?
Bah la pilule de j'aimerais bien trouver. Du coup je vais essayer cette partie là, c'était 0
64 00 qui peut être
à la fois un indice, à la fois un numéro de série mais comme le cadenas s'appelle cadenas
64, je me dis qu'il y a pas de hasard et que ça c'est pour peut-être me signifier que c'est un indice. Donc 0
64 point 0 0. Donc je vais faire 0
4. Bah non, mais oui, je peux pas aller au 4 puisque c'est le 42 qui bloque. Alors attends, je fais 0
Là je suis sur le 60. Je viens de faire
0  64 je me dis ça vaut le coup de voir si déjà il se passe un truc ou pas
Ok, là clairement j'entends mieux la bille que tout à l'heure
Après c'était point 0 0 donc je vais revenir sur le 0
Et alors je pense que le 0 0 signifie 0 et encore 0, donc peut-être que je peux faire un tour complet maintenant
Et maintenant il faudrait revenir sur le zéro. En tournant le cadran ça marche pas, mais je peux peut-être tourner le reste et pas le cadran.
J'avais un casse-tête déjà comme ça, je vous le ferai voir ça sur,
peut-être sur insta, je vous ferai une vidéo très courte avec ce principe. A savoir pour revenir au 0 je vais garder cette partie là
fixe dans mon environnement
Et je vais tourner ça, et c'est pas ça.
C'était une bonne idée pourtant.
Ca va vous sinon ? En fait je sens que je.. Je sens que je suis pas loin de la solution
Je ne dis pas que je protègerai mon scooter avec,
mais il est plutôt sécurisé quand même.
Ou alors faut tout faire à l'envers ? Bah non parce qu'il n'y a pas un seul symbole différent ici.
Bon je ré-essaye la même technique
parce que des fois aussi c'est mécanique et il suffit que j'ai mal fait un truc ou pas appuyer assez fort.
Donc je refais la même
Donc 0
J'entends un truc dedans. Donc 0  64
Est-ce que j'étais bien sur le 64 ? Je me demande si je suis pas allé sur 66 plutôt que 64.
On l'entend bien. Je reviens sur le 0.
Je vais refaire la même chose que j'ai fait tout à l'heure, à la savoir garder lui
fixe dans mon environnement 3D et tourner le reste pour accéder au deuxième 0. Ah putain, j'ai entendu la bille bouger de ouf.
Et là je viens de tout passer.
Putain je peux pas aller plus loin.
En fait tout à l'heure on était bloqués vers là,
et là on est allés vers là, avec le zéro. Genre le zéro était là à la place du 8.
Ou ...
Ou c'est suffisant, ce qui voudrait dire
qu'on a ouvert le cadenas ! On a craqué le cadenas en une vidéo ! Je suis trop content.
Désolé si vous voyez ma grosse tête ou ma grosse épaule.
On voit rien dedans !
La bille elle s'est remise. Je viens de toucher le cadran et j'ai entendu chklouck.
La bille s'est remise donc je pense que le reset est instantané en fait.
Je suis re-bloqué entre 0 et 42 là.
On voit rien du tout, rien à l'intérieur.
En mode ils ont caché tout le système, on peut pas voir comment il fonctionne.
Tout ce qu'on peut voir c'est un tout petit bout de métal, tout en bas.
Je me demande si c'est pas juste le métal de cette partie là.
Juste le métal de cette partie là, ici.
C'est peut-être juste ça. On voit rien tout se passe à l'intérieur, ils ont tout planqué les mecs.
Et là pourquoi j'ai un petit peu de lumière ? Ah oui d'accord c'est juste l'interstice.
Ok, donc remise en place du cadenas, je pense que c'est instantané.
Ah faut peut-être être à 0 !
Ouais, faut être à 0.
Est-ce que je peux ... Hé ouais,
immédiatement en fait il est bloqué. Il doit y avoir aussi une action mécanique qui fait que quand on le repousse,
ça doit pousser un truc qui doit se refermer, la bille a dû se remettre en place quand j'ai entendu le clac,
et là on est re-bloqués entre 0 et 42, et le cadenas ne peut plus s'ouvrir.
Clairement il est magique hein, il est très joli, c'est encore une fois c'est l'un des plus beaux.
Je pensais beaucoup plus galérer dessus, mais comme en ce moment je fais plein de cadenas je pense que j'ai l'esprit à les craquer,
à voir des indices partout. Partout où il n'y en a pas d'ailleurs avec le 1871.
Très très beau cadenas.
Super bel objet, super beau casse tête.
Allez, le seul petit bémol pour moi c'est que
dans ce type de cadenas, mais c'est un peu comme quand j'ouvre les boîtes, c'est qu'il n'y a qu'un sens de résolution,
c'est-à-dire une fois qu'on a ouvert, le fait de le remettre c'est facile. Mais des fois les cadenas,
vous l'avez vu déjà dans les précédentes vidéos, c'est un peu en deux fois. C'est-à-dire on galère à le
défaire et on galère aussi à le remettre en place. Là il y a vraiment qu'une seule action.
Je suis trop content.
Un de mes préférés.
Quand tu finis un casse-tête, tu as toujours un sentiment un peu ouf, je sais pas si vous avez remarqué ça. C'est à la
fois de la joie, limite de la fierté, parce que moi je suis quand même très fier d'avoir craqué le cadenas 64,
mais en même temps hyper déçu parce que tu ne peux plus jamais chercher, en fait, comment résoudre le cadenas.
C'est  un bonbon de ...
déductions qui marche qu'une seule fois quoi. Mais il est vraiment cool, il est très joli.
Clairement, de tout ceux que j'ai fait, pour l'instant ça doit être mon préféré en termes de logique et de ...
et de mystère aussi parce que je sais toujours pas ce qui est à l'intérieur.
Faudrait que je trouve une mini caméra pour aller là dedans voir ce qu'il y a. Mais il est vraiment vraiment ouf.
Bon comme toujours je vous mets un lien dans la description si vous voulez vous le procurer et puis un lien vers d'autres ...
D'autres casse-tête que j'aime bien,
et n'hésitez pas à liker la vidéo comme d'habitude, à vous abonner si ce n'est pas encore fait. A très bientôt ! Ciao !